more action so we can we can go ahead
and take the wrist strap off for this
the oh sure if this white little may
come here if you push it down that'll be
the to release the lock and and back
here Wow gotcha you're in the Navy right
oh yeah all right we're gonna pull the
pin this game here safe crack again as
Chris dimension this game will feature
HD Rumble go attempts enjoy fun strap
have you seen this one no or okay so
essentially we're gonna be trying to
feel for different kind of Rumble as we
try to unlock the safe so the screens
not really going to help you and so to
start out it's gonna be the first person
to binary sweet spot so go ahead and
hold vertically so when you find that
squeaks much like a button you're just
feel so first you'll hold 90 degrees and
you're gonna feel a different vibration
and you hold it there it's yeah like
just hold it so that kind of vibration
you just felt is what you're trying to
find once the game starts gotcha you're
trying to find three of those to find
where the vibration feels a bit
different and all that position there we
go
[Music]
[Music]